mais moi je pensais d'avoir posé les
vraies questions les questions que m'ont
posée les québécois et les québécoises
depuis le tout début de cette campagne
fait un peu avant moi je fais le tour du
québec fait deux trois fois je pense que
je vais dans toutes les régions est et
déjà vous parler des enjeux fondamentaux
la caisse d'assurance-emploi pourquoi
les trois autres participent utile dans
la caisse d'assurance emploi
contrairement à ce qu'ils prétendent et
pourquoi ne s'engage sur le port refusez
signé le traité transpacifique si la
gestion de l'oeuf n'est pas maintenu
intactes pourquoi beaucoup m'ont parlé
de la question que j'ai posée sur
l'arabie saoudite pourquoi vendre des
armes à l'arabie saoudite
pourquoi ces partis refuse-t-il par
exemple que les oléoducs norton gateway
qui sont excellent passe dans l'ouest
mais sont d'accord pour nrj est au
québec du pétrole raffiné au québec pas
consommé au québec les trois autres
partis ont la même position tout à fait
absolument absolument moi et je sens
mais je sens que les choses
je sens que les choses changent
énormément heureux je suis fier salon
tant que sujet n'est plus au bloc les
noms journée de 97 était assez difficile
en 2000 je vais fusions municipales et
quand vous me disiez comprends tout à
fait la même position sur l'énergie est
ce vous avez en partie raison
troisième chose au québec est emmené
autre chose au canada
owen rooney qui a dit que c'était sa
priorité qu'énergie s ça c'est pas des
blagues et belledune 240 dragons qui
vont comme celui qu'on a connu à
lac-mégantic est que l'horreur que ces
produits là qui vous a plu tout seul à
part ça ça babel du renouveau grande ou
et c'est parti la protège des votes
ailleurs au détriment des intérêts des
québécois des québécois c'est ça la
réalité
oui c'est intéressant votre question
parce que voyez-vous énergie s sa
nourrice volts et le transport
ferroviaire
ça ne résout pas le transport fluvial ça
va continuer d'augmenter ya ce projet là
ça ne réduit pas sa nourrice vuitton
parce que ça sans avoir saigné consommer
n'ira fini donc le québec doit continuer
doit continuer à recevoir du pétrole par
train c'était 500 wagons en 2009 s'est
rendu à 540 mille wagon c'est pas de la
blague
nous ce que l'on dit c'est pas à
akhalgori de décider ça avec l'office
national d'énergie contrôlé par les
pétrolières ni à ottawa
c'est le québec par son assemblée
nationale qui doit décider ce qui parle
sur son territoire et d'aucune façon le
pipeline énergie s ne réduit le
transport ferroviaire les experts l'ont
dit
absolument pas aucune réduction des
transports ferroviaires et fluviales
tout à fait et je pense moi que lorsque
l'on regarde ce qui se passe là les
conservateurs n'ont fait élire cinq
députés au québec ce point ici qui sont
élus c'est dans le reste du canada où
les libéraux le npd divise le va parce
qu' il est plus important de tenter de
prendre le pouvoir que de battre les
conservateurs c'est eux qui divise le
vote et qui font passer les
conservateurs
la démocratie c'est pas que le pouvoir
sinon presque une dictature c'est aussi
ce débat nécessaire débat démocratique
et il importe que les québécois et les
québécoises aient leur mot à dire à
ottawa et dans le passé on l'a prouvé en
la loi anti-gay n'y a pas existé une
utilité du bloc les commandites ce repos
était connu noté t du bloc le 3,3
milliards qu'ont été chercher lorsque
harper est minoritaire
un de l'argent qui rentre directement au
québec et les contrats pensez vous qu'on
a accepté nous le contrat des frégates à
vancouver parifex et puis dire quand les
gens du npd ont dit great d'efforts
canada et pelé députés nouvellement élus
du npd au québec qui ont aussi soit sa
première fois je voulais être un
politique mais mme galipeau cas des kits
n'ont rien à dire ils se faufilent ils
essaient de le pauvre voir les
journalistes et ont pris la peine
d'écrire un communiqué sachez que nous
n'avons aucun commentaire à faire sa
première autorisation tout à fait non
c'est pas ça que je dis là d'une part il
ya de bonnes chances qu'un gouvernement
minoritaire
on voit se profiler il est hors de
question qu'on on appuie un gouvernement
les conservateurs je lui ai dit
clairement tout début de campagne
or et pas de chèque en blanc prenons les
deux cas là pendant les deux cas les
frappes
j'ai dit que j'étais d'accord sur le
niqab est bien ce pas de nouvelles
positions du bloc on a commencé la
discussion en 2000 voyez-vous des
chantiers de réflexion sur l'identité
mais c'est pour terminer ma réponse je
ne suis pas un conservateur loin de là
écoutez bien les bouchard taylor soit
entièrement d'accord avec ça et bouchard
taylor a repris les positions du bloc
québécois
c'est ça quand on disait nous les
personnes qui représentent l'état et
l'autorité que pouvoir de coercition
policiers les juges gardiens de prison
pas de signes ostentatoires et toujours
le visage découvert portières condition
que disent les conservateurs les
conservateurs disent lors de
l'assermentation pas de visage couvert
seulement lors de l'assermentation une
fois dans la vie il vient de déclarer
aujourd'hui le monsieur blé ni et
caniche à quoi vient de dire tous les
deux que lors du vote n'ayant sont pas
là le voit qu'il veut le visage couvert
comme les libéraux comme les [ __ ] les
services rendus dans la fonction
publique ou affaires reçues ou offert la
fonction publique à visage couvert aussi
s'est demandé à la femme de s'effacer de
l'espace public et ça c'est un principe
sacré or on est le seul parti qui est
totalement en accord non seulement avec
une très grande majorité de la
population québécoise 93% je pense
l'assemblée nationale du québec là les
libéraux et les péquistes québec
solidaire la can ça se peut que les
conservateurs aient fait ça ce fait les
grosses vagues est ce une raison pour
nous taire est ce une raison on va dire
on connait sa naissance une salle elle
la question que faites vous de la motion
unanime de l'assemblée nationale ce
point va rater sa maison rue du sort
cette série à deux semaines
unanimité la gauche l'ado non non non
non je pense et des questions des
caisses rouge où dimanche entièrement
d'accord avec vous il y aurait pu régler
ça depuis quatre ans ils étaient
majoritaires mais est ce que parce
qu'ils sont porte aux opportunistes que
nous on bosse terre ou convoi est
opportuniste comme le npd et les
libéraux pour pas déplaire à certains
pour gagner des votes à toronto
vancouver ont pas fait ce prix là moi
j'ai dit ça en 2000 j'ai dit ça à
bouchard taylor je le redis aujourd'hui
et ceux qui dirigent actuellement spanu
93 % des québécoises et québécois sont
d'accord avec ça l'assemblée nationale
du québec le maire de québec le maire de
montréal le maire de saguenay et les
trois partis fédéralistes l'autre côté 1
un instant les conservateurs sont
d'accord sur deux des trois choses avec
les avec les deux autres partis dont que
ceux qui sont le plus ensemble ce sont
les conservateurs les libéraux et le npd
c'est pas nous non je n'en dors je les y
moi pas question parce que en 2004 on a
signé une entente avec stephen harper et
jack layton et jack layton bien signé
l'étoile à ceux qui veulent mettre ça en
question c'est parce qu'ils veulent ils
vont pas revoir les soirs la lette est
toujours là et on a changé les
règlements de la chambre en 2008 on a
également moi j'ai contacté stéphane
guillon je me souviens c'est un certain
jeudi matin de mémoire et jack layton à
7h15 si vous faites une coalition on
pourrait vous appuyez 11 jours n'a pas
de plate forme ça tombe bien j'en ai eu
leur est proposé et ont repris 80% de
cette plate forme d'une très bonne idée
une excellente plate forme et par la
suite les libéraux ont concédé ont mis
fin la coalition et monsieur harper hors
prix plus ou moins lassant de nos
propositions plus que moi sur les
infrastructures parce que en période
d'austérité et monsieur mulcair la même
position que monsieur harper l'austérité
il a voté pour monsieur couillard
monsieur malterre s'agit pour
l'hostilité de monsieur couillard contre
l'austérité de monsieur cissé la corrèze
oui mais regardez nos positions plus que
progresser ce truc sont pas progressiste
c'est des gens comme monsieur molière
qui est d'accord pour vendre des armes à
l'arabie saoudite c'est très progressif
ceux qui parlent d'environnement piquer
son compte pour deux projets qui vont
naître en compte l'environnement ils
sont cachés sont pas venus rassemblement
contre énergie assez progressistes ce
mois mais monsieur monsieur monsieur
manière le maintiendrai il l'a bien dit
il l'a bien dit ce qui pige en caisse
d'assurance emploi
c'est bien monsieur marc hé monsieur
trudeau monsieur harper c'est très
progressif et sur l'ensemble des enjeux
sur la gestion de l'offre par exemple je
leur ai demandé tous les toits
allez-vous refusé de signer
à traiter transpacifique si la gestion
de l'offre mais pas m 2e étape d'abord
on verra on verra si et qu'elle soit la
poignée de députés savaient quand un
pays non j'avais jamais posé cette
question ou npd quand ça veut pas un
seul député au québec pendant 50 ans
d'accord donc donc à ce moment là le
plus possible mieux on travaillera très
fort on va bien représenter les
québécois et on est les seuls à dire
très clairement pourquoi mettre la
gestion de leurs sur la table alors que
les généreuses subventions aux fermiers
américains ne sont pas sur la table
et si les trois partis ont refusé de
répondre à ma question
lors du débat c'est que les trois
veulent protéger des votes dans l'ouest
canadien
c'est ça la raison il faut conclure que
seulement 25 à nouveau parti
démocratique à ce nom depuis plus de 50
ans
le scottish national party été créée en
1934 et il se trouve encore jeune alors
on est plus jeune que tout ce monde font
rencontre qu'on continue la lutte on
n'est pas des lâches
on est des gens qui se tiennent debout
qui veut les pays et moi je pour le vote
stratégique je pense que tous ceux qui
veulent les pays ont intérêt à voter
pour des gens qui veulent le conduisent
le pays le québec soit un pays souverain
et non pas pour des gens comme thomas
mulcair qui était l'avocat d'alliance
québec contre la loi 101
moi qui vous remercie